(playful piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal,
naked,
large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet, filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are,
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans
like you.
(electronic music)
- [Ajit Varki] And so
we humans ask ourselves,
who are we?
What are we doing here?
Where did we come from?
How did we get here?
And where are we going?
As you know, Carta focuses
on two of these questions,
in the form of the study of anthropogeny
explaining the origin of humans.
And we access all disciplines
that we can possibly access
to interact, to come to some conclusions
on these two questions.
And this symposium is
co-sponsored by Carta and
the KAVLI Institute for Brain and Mind.
And we're a transdisciplinary
collaboration
between faculty at UC San Diego and Salk,
along with interested
scientists at other institutions
and our mission is to explore
and explain the origins
of the human phenomenon.
And so along with me as Co-Directors,
are Rusty Gage and Margaret Schoeninger,
and Associate Director Pascal Gagneux.
And the KAVLI Institute
is also run by Rusty,
along with Nick Spitzer
and Ralph Greenspan.
And a special thanks
to our major sponsors,
the Harold and Leila Mathers
Charitable Foundation New York,
Howard Chester, Executive Director,
and in this symposium,
the KAVLI Institute.
And a special thank you
to Annette Merle-Smith,
for her support of the
Graduate Specialization
in Anthropogeny.
And a thank you to the supporters
of the James Handelman Endowment
for the Exploration of Anthropogeny.
These lists will be circulating
during the intermissions.
Special thank you to Cheryl
and Kenney Griffiths,
for sponsoring this
symposium's closed captioning
of the videos on Youtube, as
they'll come out eventually.
And of course, thank you to
the many individual
supporters who are named here,
and I'm just showing
the slides very briefly,
we'll show them as we go along.
And special thanks to the Carta staff,
Ingrid, Rachel, Kate, Linda and Jesse,
and the UC TV group,
Rich, Matt, Steve Anderson,
Marci and Domenick.
And Kent Schnoeker and Michael Jeffs,
and the guitarist of
course, who we just heard,
George Svoboda.
So with that I'll hand over to the chairs.
- [Tim White] Thank you,
good afternoon and welcome.
On Sunday March 30th,
1997,
I received Professor Varki's announcement
of something called Carta.
The vision was ambitious-
to create a unique, San
Diego-based enterprise
to engage scholars and
students at the highest level
across the wide range of
disciplines contributing
knowledge about our place
in the natural world.
Or, as the initial announcement put it,
"the ultimate objective of the group
"is to completely explain
"the phenomenon of humans".
(audience laughter)
Now that was a tall
order even 21 years ago.
Your presence here,
and your presence online
is one indicator of the
success of this enterprise.
Carta's local and global
impacts have been impressive
by any measure,
making it a shining jewel in the crown of
the University of California system.
So Carta was launched in 1997.
That was a decade
before the first generation iPhone.
And here we are today.
I'm going to read a
passage from Stewart Brand,
who you may know as the editor
of the Whole Earth Catalog,
and President of the Long Now Foundation.
Brand wrote in 2011,
"civilization is revving itself
"into a pathologically
short attention span.
"The trend might be coming from
"the acceleration of technology,
"the short horizon perspective
of market-driven economics,
"the next election
perspective of democracies,
"or the distractions of
personal multi-tasking."
That's your reminder to please
turn your cell phones off.
(audience laughter)
That was only seven years ago.
Today's invited speakers
come from a wide range of disciplines.
I'm going to illustrate a
bit of the temporal spectrum,
that they'll cover.
I'll start with this.
This is a cobble.
An original artifact
from the bottom of a gorge in Tanzania.
It was shaped by someone,
1.8 million years ago,
and it represents the
earliest technology made
by our ancestors.
Literally on the other hand,
(audience laughter)
This,
is a now obsolete iPhone.
(audience laughter)
The range of technology.
Today in the invaluable spaces
that Carta has established,
we will be treated to
an intellectual banquet,
that will reach far beyond
these two technological markers.
On behalf of all of us here,
and all of you out there online,
let me thank the visionaries
who created Carta,
and the supporters and students and staff
whose efforts continue to make this broad,
and productive intellectual space
available to the widest audiences.
(electronic music)